there will soon be a new way to
calculate your credit score the company
behind FICO the country's most widely
used credit score is launching the ultra
FICO score early next year
it looks at cash accounts and banking
behavior to determine if you were able
to pay back a loan or a credit card
balance CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what this could
mean for your money Jill good morning
good morning so how is this new score
different from the traditional FICO
score the old score was from 350 to 850
the the score took into account your
payment history did you pay your bills
on time how much credit did you have
available what was the length of this
credit history what's the mix of credit
you have and as you said in the intro
we're now going to weave in something
very different
what is your banking behavior do you
have four hundred dollars in an account
has this account been open for a long
time do you pay your utilities out of
this the notion here is that there are a
lot of people who don't have access to
credit or have low credit scores but
they could actually repay loans and
they're being shut out of the credit
market right now so who does that
benefit most then well I think if
cording to FICO there could be up to
four million people who could see their
scores increased by 20 points and these
are people who probably would fall into
the less good category so below 650 to
700 and if those scores were to increase
by 20 points that could be the
difference between getting a loan and
not getting a loan or saving you
hundreds maybe even thousands of dollars
a year on your loan repayment so the
last financial crisis was in part
created by a lot of bad credit a lot of
loans that went bad are we talking here
about housing loans credit card loans
school what kind and what's the risk so
it is all loans and I think that the
real downside is that you have a new
group of people who say we want credit
but maybe they don't understand how
dangerous credit can be right the
average credit card interest rates 17%
the average balance 5502
credit but I'm back on my feet and I
want to buy a house I want to buy a car
and for those people this could be a
really differentiating change to the
score your credit score is so incredibly
important it is guard it with your life
absolutely thank you Jim mm-hmm